nowhere is more secure than an scp
foundation facility they make fort knox
look like a revolving door with a spare
key under the mat that's why when
someone or something can infiltrate
without even being noticed it's
considered a major threat and doing
exactly that is what put a mysterious
group of insurgents known as the
serpent's hand on the map but this group
of interest isn't just famous for its
ability to sneak into foundation's
strongholds like a lot of the scp
foundation's biggest threats from the
scarlet king to the chaos insurgency the
roots of the serpent's hand are closer
than they think the foundation's first
official brush with the serpent's hand
came shortly after they contained
scp-268
an irish tweed wool newsboy cap believed
to have been created sometime in the
1800s the only identifying mark on the
cap is a label with the following phrase
written in middle irish the garden is
the serpent's place initially believed
to be a reference to the serpent in the
biblical garden of eden this
euclid-class scp is a double-edged sword
it gives the user a useful supernatural
ability at a terrifying supernatural
cost anyone wearing the cap appears so
utterly unremarkable that nobody is able
to take notice of them and when they
leave a person's general area of
awareness they're quickly forgotten the
user isn't invisible but they might as
well be if you're a person whose line of
work involves sneaking in subterfuge or
if you're just a major introvert this
sounds like a dream come true however
like a lot of anomalies this dream can
quickly become a nightmare if someone
wears the cap repeatedly or for too long
at one time they risk the effects of the
cap becoming permanent even when it's
removed you can become a forgotten
person impossible to notice and remember
even to those closest to you why anyone
would want such a fade as a mystery so
it came as a surprise to the foundation
when the hat suddenly disappeared from
secure containment replaced by a note
reading thanks i needed my hat back ls
who was this mysterious ls and was the
anomaly truly theirs prior to
containment scientists security
officials and administrators hoped this
would be an isolated incident but ls was
far from done and even worse for the
foundation ls was now armed with a
perfect anomalous tool to make their
next containment breach even smoother
the next incident was known as security
breach incident x-23 and was committed
against the extremely valuable site 19
the largest foundation site there is
most humiliating of all for the
foundation security team working there
security footage indicated that ls
simply strolled into the base without
being noticed
scp-268 was working wonders
this time ls had a new target scp-914
an anomalous machine also known as the
clockworks this machine originally
tested by the famously emotionalist dr
charles gears has the ability to refine
any object placed into its chambers into
a greater version of their original
selves often with strange and anomalous
results you can probably see why someone
wanting to utilize anomalies for their
own gain would take such a keen interest
in this one ls breeze past the guards
inexplicably destroyed the file for
scp-408
a taped song that causes unchecked
cellular growth and made their way
towards 914
unfortunately a researcher who was
working on 914 was murdered by ls during
the breach we have no idea what they did
with 914 perhaps they refined 268 to act
as an even more effective stealth tool
without its unpleasant side effects
maybe they made the daring move of
refining themselves we'll never know all
we do know is that this time ls left a
letter it was long rambling and
philosophical with no incriminating
information that could be used to
identify the mysterious figure they
signed off the letter with i leave you
with one final truth the garden is the
serpent's place the divinities of fear
and order who come to walk in the cool
evening air are only visitors do not
fail to see the evil hiding in the light
nor the aromatic beauty of the palest
flower of darkness signed sincerely ls
these repeated references to the serpent
clued the foundation in on the
affiliation of this new troublemaker a
growing group of interest named the
serpent's hand but really who are the
serpents hand what do they want what is
their connection to other active groups
of interest like the chaos insurgency
and the global code coalition and was
this mysterious ls figure the leader of
the group or just another agent these
were all the questions on the minds of
the foundation's best and brightest
tactical thinkers but the answers didn't
come easy during the serpent's hands
investigations the foundation found an
unlikely ally in what is usually one of
their biggest opponents the global
occult coalition the goc had dealt with
the serpent's hand before and understood
their central philosophy whereas the
foundation and the goc were both
committed to acting in secret and
maintaining a sense of normality the
serpent's hand wanted the exact opposite
they wanted to destroy the secrecy
around the anomalous and supernatural
and reveal the existence of it all to
the general public while the foundation
and the goc think this is crazy the
serpent's hand aren't just insane
architects who want to unleash chaos
across the world in fact they actually
have some pretty interesting points the
serpent's hand acknowledges that the
supernatural can be dangerous but much
like natural disasters and crime will
the public benefit from not knowing
about them members of the serpent's hand
also fight for the rights of non-violent
anomalous entities particularly sentient
and sapient beings they find the
foundation's habit of containing them
and the goc's habit of killing them
barbaric and will openly use and
collaborate with anomalies to further
their goals like how ls is a keen
operator of 268 for their infiltration
missions at least 177 individuals
belonging to the serpent's hand have
been identified many of which who have
actively performed raids on foundation
sites across the globe it was a mystery
to the foundation how such a small
number of members could run rings around
them and seemingly be everywhere at once
until a revelation was delivered by the
global occult coalition the serpent's
hand have an informal headquarters in an
anomalous location known as the
wanderers library an ancient and
seemingly limitless archive containing
every book from every dimension in the
multiverse this location exists outside
of space and time and can be accessed
through a global network of
interdimensional portals known as the
ways like a supernatural guerrilla
soldier members of the serpent's hand
would exit from one of the ways raid a
foundation or goc site and then escape
back into another one of the ways using
the wanderers library as a safe zone the
library was a convenient way to access
and steal from sites worldwide with
impunity increasing their stock of
anomalous items and beings each time
while performing raids and stealing
anomalies feel like textbook chaos
insurgency behavior the serpent's hand
have an extremely frosty relationship
with the insurgency too often seeing
them as greedy erratic and short-sighted
the serpent's hand has a series of
catchy nicknames for its various foes it
refers to the foundation as the jailers
the goc is the book burners and the
chaos insurgency as the madman the
foundation even formed a new task force
known as the bookworms explicitly for
serpent's hand-related missions while
the foundation has engaged in a number
of raids and skirmishes on the serpent's
hand since their feud began they've
never been able to gather any
information about who gives the orders
only the global coat coalition have been
able to successfully perform a raid on
the wanderers library an act that was
extremely difficult and costly it also
earned the geocod as the serpent's hands
public enemy number one a role the
foundation isn't eager to take from them
with the unlimited knowledge present in
the wanderers library and the mysterious
nature of their command structure
this group manages to be a formidable
enemy for the foundation despite its
small size what the foundation doesn't
know is that there actually is no
command structure for the serpent's hand
they're a decentralized group of
splinter cells and lone wolves acting
out a philosophy rather than a specific
mission this way of working is so alien
to the highly regimented structures of
the foundation and the goc it's no
surprise that they're stumped by it this
still leaves us with one more question
central to the whole mystery if not the
leader of this organization who exactly
is ls
to answer this we must return once more
to dr charles ogden gears the cold and
robotic foundation scientist in charge
of
scp-914 research if all the ways dr
gears has been described so far has made
you think he wouldn't be a particularly
warm and loving father you'd be
absolutely right just ask his estranged
daughter alison chao allison never
forgave gears for abandoning her and her
mother and she now does everything she
can to get revenge on him and his
precious foundation but here's the
problem the gears of this dimension is
not the only one who has a child with an
axe to grind gears has been a deadbeat
dad in a number of dimensions so much so
that these disgruntled daughters
converge in the wanders library to plot
their revenge across dimensions together
this collective of alice and chows
sometimes believed to just be one
allison is known to the foundation as
the black queen however they themselves
more commonly refer to their daughter
support group turned terrorist
organization as the little sisters or if
you'd prefer the abbreviation ls
while the serpent's hand has no leader
the little sisters are some of its most
devoted and dangerous warriors they're
intelligent coordinated and due to their
obsession with dr gears personally
invested in hitting the foundation where
it hurts after all
that's what the serpent's hand is all
about striking out against the
oppressors who keep a strangle hold on
the truth throwing off the chains
imposed by the foundation and the
violence visited upon anomalies by the
global occult coalition if the serpent's
hand gets their way one day there may be
a glorious world where humans and
anomalies knowingly coexist it is a nice
thing to imagine utopian even but the
foundation's greatest concern about the
serpent's hand isn't that they're evil
it is that they're naive while the
serpent's hand don't wish to usher in
the apocalypse it doesn't mean they
won't by complete accident their
kindness and understanding towards
anomalies may one day make them a
perfect band of useful idiots for an
entity with far darker intentions and
one day they may just release something
that would really be better locked away
now go check out scp chaos insurgency
explained and
scp-001 which is the real scp-001
for more deep lore from the world of the
scp foundation